this movie is an insult to zack snyder
this version of justice league is not
his film
a director is like the conductor of a
film right
he didn't conduct the editing process he
didn't conduct the visual effects he
didn't conduct a lot of it he didn't he
wasn't involved in the reshoots
so what they did though was they made
this movie and then they said it was
directed by him
the cast doesn't even support this movie
you know what i mean
yeah yeah the film the cinematographer
doesn't support this movie
it's publicly known that the people
involved in this movie do not support
this movie well and you're releasing
this 4k trailer
a month after zack snyder's justice
league
how's it going reject nation greg here
john here
uh so i don't know what the heck
happened yesterday
it was a busy day i did collab with 3c
films keep a lookout for that next week
but i'm not here to plug that here to
talk about something that i was late to
discovering
i don't think john knows about yet i was
late to discovering this i discovered it
right before i went to bed i didn't
discover this from any other outlet
i discovered it because i was going
through the notification bells and then
i saw
on warner brothers page justice league
4k
trailer i was like oh cool then i
clicked on it and i was like damn this
thing's got like 25 000 dislikes
then i realized this is the joss whedon
version
this is the justice league first
why and it's strange it's like i'm
passionate about restoring the snyder
verse and
then i know there's a lot of people who
have lost faith that it's going to
happen even
who i'm assuming is zack snyder's best
friend grace randolph
who has recently been talking about how
don't count on it
it's not gonna happen and this is the
first time
and i don't know why i felt like i took
it
personal that they did this i actually
thought this was so
insulting it's really insulting
it seems like ever since zack snyder's
justice league was released
warner brothers has been doing anything
they can
to bury it right away it seems like
that's their
ultimatum that's their super big motive
right with the uh and sarnoff sarnoff
skarnoff whatever that startup boris
karloff whatever her interview was just
like shut that [ __ ] down
and then they go and release this
trailer like wait a minute let me
okay let me try to under let me try to
understand where warner brothers is
coming from on this all right
what is it at while we're filming this
right now
golly as we're filming this i gotta take
a screenshot of it 26k
dislikes 1.8k likes wow
i thought this was a good idea what a
what a ratio boy
who thought this was a good idea yeah
that that's either quite
pointed or quite oblivious and i'm not
sure which one
and it's like if there's any justice
league version you should be trying to
bury it's
this one right here this is the one you
ought to ignore
yeah because it seems like no matter
your feelings on the snyder cut most
people agree
on justice league not being great not
being a particularly well-assembled
movie in the first place i saw a report
recently that said like wb is kind of
taking a lot of the
fan outcry personally and i i could kind
of see that
from this i think this is a statement to
that as a big fu
and especially with the other venn
diagram of like joss whedon's
fall from grace and and you know the
other just reports
like not related to justice league that
have come out about him to then go and
elevate that is also kind of funky in
the greater
scheme of things you know and then this
is a movie that was panned left and
right
yeah i don't i don't get it i watched
this trailer and i'm like this doesn't
even tonally represent what this movie
is the music they have going over at the
visuals this is having an
accurate representation who wants to get
a 4k version of this so i was like all
right look normally i try to understand
like both sides right so
let me in real time let me try to
understand
what they're doing and why they would do
this zack snyder's justice league they
don't want it to be considered the
official canon they have
other movies already filmed already in
post-production some are gearing up to
film
right now movies like aquaman 2 the
flash they got dc
fandom coming up they got a lot going in
store and you know what
i'm excited for a good chunk of them i i
really am at the same time though
to put this out it's like they
completely
negate and forget what the whole purpose
of zack snyder's justice league was
justice league critically panned
audience
panned this movie zack snyder's justice
league was an outcry we want
the great version we want the good
version now whether you
like that movie or not whether you
thought it was overrated or whatever
bottom line
critics higher rated score audience
score higher rated
people who don't really like the zack
snyder movies a lot of people ended up
really liking this i'm not gonna say
everybody
but a lot of people really did i guess
like trying to understand warner
brothers perspective
is ever since they released zack
snyder's justice league it's been a lot
about hashtag restore the snyder verse
so what they're trying to do
is bury it this is not the way to go
about it you were better off ignoring
warner brothers was 100 better off just
ignoring the hashtag
ignore what people were saying the
timing is
ridiculous to me the timing is insane
silly zack snyder's justice league it's
still fresh
it's still for a movie that we that
people have been demanding and
ruminating on
and theorizing about for years
it's a fresh release still even if zack
snyder's justice league hadn't come out
who's gonna give a [ __ ] about this movie
is it
just exactly a month from from the
justice league drop even
it's a month away like they're clearly
trying to be like screw you guys
forget zack snyder's justice league this
is the cannon i'm like
what the who wants this who's going to
buy this the the 1.1 000 people who
uploaded this
that's the only reason i could imagine
for them releasing this is them going
like i guess let's cash in on the
you know hype around zack snyder's
justice league and sell more copies of
our other justice leagues make money on
everything but at the same time
it just seems so strange to me that a
company that spends so much time
fixating apparently on what people are
saying and
adjusting for that i can't imagine they
wouldn't anticipate
some kind of response like this at least
looking at the like to dislike ratio and
what this is obviously going to do to
fans because again i think that is a
good point that like no matter what your
attachment is emotionally to zack
snyder's justice league
pretty much everybody has come around in
some fashion to say that hey
this is a much better made film it's a
more
competent movie and so yeah i don't i
don't know why they would want to go
back now
and elevate this it's like you made the
decision to put zack snyder's justice
league out there
whether or not yeah and you put
money into it you greenlit it's on hbo
max you did it
stick to that gun for a little while at
the least uh reaction it's like
it's got to confuse a couple people too
right you know you got to have a couple
people coming and being like oh there's
a 4k version of zack snyder's i
thought that's what i thought it was
like when i clicked on it yeah exactly
like it's
it is a very peculiar thing for them to
have done
and i yeah i just can't tell if this was
like completely tone deaf or
uh yeah in some kind of retaliation
i think a hundred percent it's a
retaliation i don't doubt that
for a minute on top of that too not only
what's infuriating about it is it it's
such a direct insult to zack snyder
this movie is an insult to zack snyder
it's not his film
this version of justice league is not
his film a director
is like the composer he's the conductor
of a film right
he didn't conduct the editing process he
didn't conduct the visual effects he
didn't
conduct a lot of it he didn't he wasn't
involved in the reshoots so what they
did though was
they made this movie and then they said
it was directed by him when you watch
that film it doesn't say directed by
joss whedon
it's directed by zach snyder that's what
it says
and then the cast comes out the cast
doesn't even support this movie
you know what i mean yeah yeah the p the
cinematographer doesn't support this
movie
it's publicly known people involved in
this movie do not support this movie
well and you're releasing this 4k
trailer
a month after zack snyder's justice
league well and and for all that goes
toward joss whedon and yes i mean some
of that is
on him but like really the conductor of
this cut is the studio because they got
somebody who would at least fall in line
with their exact
needs and go with that and so it seems
like yeah a move where they just want to
like solidify the
the choices that they made back in the
day or something i don't know
it's like why yeah even if zack snyder's
justice league did underperform
even if daxner's justly didn't come out
no one's gonna give a [ __ ] about this
and all people would say is why are you
releasing this and not the sniper cut
is it oh yeah people don't want this let
this
one just sink the other one can still be
considered canon for all they want well
you know there's that film theory that
that justifies how they both co-exist
after the reception of zack snyder's
justice league the
the love that that movie got even for
people who didn't like it but were like
yeah it's better and it looks better
a visual everything about it yeah it
flows it feels like an actual movie
yada yada yada zack snyder's justice
league release
also created the conversation of wow
that other one is worse than i thought
yeah why would you do for a movie
that has visuals
one of the most hated aspects of this
movie is the visual language and the
changes in the colors and the effects
that they put in so
why would you also want to hype up your
extra clear
super crisp digital hd version people
hate the look too like it's like
reminding you
this yeah reminds people if they were
gonna do this then i don't know i guess
go
back and make those step and wolf
effects look better or something like
justify its existence in 4k because
like when it came out in theaters people
were dogging on the look and the effects
and everything
oh man that's a stupid ass maneuver i
still hope we get screeners for
you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know and keep those checks coming
for the reviews
yeah you know and uh thanks for sending
over mortal kombat yeah i appreciate
that
issues out with hbo max
these are complex ecosystems whoever is
in charge of
justice league it seems like you're
maybe
a stray at the moment stupid ass move
all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below holy crap
that was wow
i that's odd and awkward i don't think
i've been on the video to hour i've been
like
just been like no i know this is good
catharsis
you need to get it out anyway
subscribe subscribe click that bell hit
that like button jesus christ
see you guys soon